[MUSIC]
In preparing for this interview one of the
things that I learned about you is
that you make a point to eat lunch with
most of your employees at HSN.
Particularly for their first, fifth, tenth
and 20th anniversaries.
And, I've heard you're known for sitting
down and asking,
why are you at HSN and what keeps you
there?
So Mindy, to get us started, would you
mind if I
ask you why are you at HSN, and what keeps
you there?
>> That's a great question and to your
point, I learn more from those breakfasts
and those lunches than you can by reading
any report, or doing anything.
You got to have the pulse of your company,
what people are thinking,
what they're feeling and I believe that
culture trumps strategy, and I know people
have written about that but I think that
you can't have a long-term,
successful, sustainable company unless you
have an
incredibly engaged culture, and I've been
fortunate.
To work for many of those, and it
certainly helped me in the transformation
of HSN.
But I think where I wanna start, kind, to
kind of get to
the point of how I ended up making the
decision to go to HSN.
>> Great.
>> Which at the time was a pretty big risk
according to many people and I'm known
as somewhat of an unconventional risk
taker and it really started [CROSSTALK].
>> Pop ahead to the next,.
>> Yeah.
>> She's just driving the interview for me
[LAUGH].
>> You know, my career, and, and the fact
that I'm
even in this business it was definitely
not my original path so.
You know, just quick story, I was I
finished high school at 16 in my Junior
Year.
You know, went into college I was in
English literature and
Philosophy major and there I was in my
last semester at GW.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I was engaged to be married to my,
highschool sweetheart who was gonna
become a doctor and, I was graduating and
I was gonna go to law school.
So if any of you can relate it's every
stereotype of a Jewish mother's dream.
[LAUGH] Yeah.
And I was an adopted kid.
First one to ever go the college.
So everything was in the stars.
And I literally.
And I'm sure.
You know?
I say that I woke up.
But I'm sure it was on my mind but I did
wake up one morning and say that, I cant
do this.
I'm living someone elses life and I have
to live my life.
>> Mm-hm, mm-hm.
>> And with that, I called my folks and I
said, I have something to tell you.
Not getting married.
I'm not going to law school.
And I'm leaving school right now and I'm
moving
to New York cuz I'm gonna figure it out.
And that's what I did.
And I moved to Manhattan in 1997, and said
I
know that I want to be in a creative
field.
I might not be the creator.
And I don't know how I said it in my head
at the time,
but I said I want to be in the business of
making creative people successful.
And it's the first time that I realized
that, you
know, having the power to do that was, it
really gave
me the feeling of if you believe in
yourself and you really, to the
point that Jennifer made, passion,
purpose, and impact.
You know, and the quote that you see up
there.
Risk-taking and boldness is the essence of
transformation.
That moment that I picked up the phone
that
I made that decision that transformed my
entire life.
It wasn't picking up the phone and going,
I'm gonna
be the CEO of a public company, I was
picking up
the phone that I was gonna do what I was
passionate about and I'm going to be able
to take chances.
And so I think through the course of my
career
I think that people now have made it you
know.
Kind of a joke, okay what is she
gonna do next, because its gonna be
something different.
But, you know, it was, you know, leaving
Tommy Hilfiger
to go run Chaps Ralph Lauren when that was
the hottest
company but I knew that there were gonna
be very few
opportunities for a woman president in the
men's wear industry or.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Deciding to leave a company when I
didn't feel the values of the
CEO of that company lined up with me and I
quit without having another job.
Which made Ralph Lauren come and hire me
cuz I'd been running another business.
It was making a decision to start up Polo
Jeans.
It was making a decision to leave Polo
Jeans and
go to Nike which was also very
unconventional cuz I was
one of the first outsiders to really, come
in to
the company, especially you know, the
fashion doyenne from New York.
And then fast forward to how I made a
decision to, to go to HSN.
You know I'd been at Nike for six years,
and it was a spectacular experience.
I worship at the altar.
Phil Knight he's an amazing man.
And I had great opportunities at that
company,
I was the most senior woman, in the
organization.
I ran their global apparel business, but I
also had the opportunity to
spearhead kind of their transformation to
really be more emotionally connected to
women.
Some of the work on the Nike foundation
and the girl effect.
But I was at a pivotal point in my career.
I was in my late 40s and they had just
announced a new CEO, a new president, both
of whom
were about 50 and had been at the company
a
long time and, most importantly they were
in very good health.
So as that succession plan wasn't looking
like it was happening, [LAUGH] so fast
but it was truly like you know, what was
life after Nike gonna be like?
Where was I gonna go?
And I think, you know, too many people
were like she's gonna go run
the Gap or she's gonna go run this, and I
just knew that wasn't the
case and I had the opportunity to travel
the world and really see how technology
was changing the landscape, much more so
yet than it had in the United States.
So really the explosion of mobile in Japan
and what was happening.
You know around all the marketing efforts,
whether it be the Olympics or World Cup.
And, I said if I gonna do anything I want
to be in a direct to consumer business.
Because I'd worked with all these great
story telling brands and we would create
the narrative around the product and we
would create the technology, for example
at Nike.
And we'd have all these stories.
And then I would see my dreams dashed.
>> Hm.
>> By going onto a selling floor and
nobody
was telling the story the right way to the
customer.
So I said I wanted direct-to-consumer
business.
I want a business that's gonna be able to
take advantage of
what's happening in technology and what's
happening in changes in consumer behavior.
Cuz the way consumers were consuming,
right?
Media, information how people were
changing their habits of shopping.
How could I take advantage of that?
And so when I got this call from Barry
Diller, to say I got a call from
a recruiter that, that Barry Diller wants
to talk
to you about going to take over IAC
Retail.
And I said that's great, but what the hell
is IAC Retail?
I never even heard of it.
And they said well, it's, you know, HSN
and this portfolio of these catalog and
e-commerce brands.
Some of those I had heard.
And I said, well, you know not really sure
but [UNKNOWN] wanna have lunch with
[UNKNOWN] but if I wanna have lunch with
[UNKNOWN] you better have a point of view.
So give me two weeks let me do all my
due dilligence, let me see if this is
something really interesting.
So, I completely immersed myself in the
Business and the, the
brand and the competition in the market
place and I'll never forget.
I was, I'm watching and I'm glued, and I
wasn't even familiar
with it before, I'm glued to this channel,
you know, like constantly.
And my husband's like, oh my God, are we
watching this again?
[LAUGH] And I also was a big Food Network
freak, right?
I love Food Network, so this was eight
years ago.
And I'm going, what would I do with this,
what would I do with this?
How can I make it more engaging and
interesting.
>> Hm.
>> And all of a sudden, I was watching
Food Network and I clicked over to HSN and
Wolfgang
Puck, who is the only person in this
video,
that was on HSN at that time eight years
ago.
None of those other people had been
launched.
And the light bulb went off, and I said,
we
have to stop thinking of this as a selling
channel.
>> Hm.
>> And we have to start thinking of it
as a network that gonna inspire people to
want things.
I started getting really excited.
Well we could be like HGTV and Food
Network and
Style and DIY and we can transport people
through experiences.
And that's when I had lunch with Barry and
I said, okay, here's the big idea.
If you are willing to buy init this idea,
I am willing to take this plunge and do
this.
And if you are not, it's not really
interesting in
great Barry fashion, because he optimise
that, he'll say go for.
Now, little did I know, yes I was the
eightieth CEO in ten years.
The business is stalled.
It was broken.
But you know, I think that sometimes the
biggest challenges actually transport you
to the greatest places.
>> Mm-hm.
So you decided to join HSN as CEO.
>> In the first 90 days what was
your top priority when you walked into the
business?
>> So you know, I, I knew that, when you
have
eightieth CEO's in ten years, that's so
disruptive to any culture.
And, what happens is, the culture freezes.
I always use the expression, it's like
Mrs. Havesham in Great Expectations, you
know?
There's cobb webs, you know?
People are just waiting for the next
person to go.
So, no strategy has been implemented.
The business wasn't performing so, people
were really feeling downtrodden.
What were their opportunities gonna be for
success?
They were trailing, number two against the
competition.
And, so, you know, I knew that I was gonna
have to make people feel that something
was very, very different.
So, my head of HR actually called me and
said and I had not visited the
campus before I took the job, because they
were making all these changes before I
came in.
And she said, well how do you want me
arrange for your first day?
And I said let me ask you a question,
what does any other employee do on their
first day?
And she said well they go to employee
orientation.
And she said, really?
I said absolutely, cuz it's gonna give me
an insight, and
I think it's gonna make people feel that
it is different.
>> Hm.
>> So there I am, my first day, I go into
this
room and there's, like, 25 people,
and everybody goes around and introduces
themselves.
And somebody goes well I'm a merchandising
assistant, I'm in backstage television,
I'm in
call center, and they get to me and I say
I'm the new CEO.
[LAUGH] And you could see.
Well that [UNKNOWN] down went to
orientation.
I was in the call center, I was in
backstage
television, I was going to creative, I was
understanding the shows.
I actually answered calls.
Well what happened, it went viral.
It went viral throughout the entire
organisation.
So by the next day when I got up and did
my first town hall.
A, it humanized me.
B, it gave me context of how to articulate
what it was we needed to do.
>> Hm.
>> And it made people that I was going to
be accessible and authentic.
And so when I got up the next morning, and
I, I said,
here's why I joined the company, and we
were talking earlier about story telling.
I knew the first story I had to tell was
why was I there, why
was I passionate about the future this
company, and I had to make it personal.
But because I had that experience I was
able to make it personal.
>> Hm.
>> So all of a sudden people felt, that it
is different.
We do have a future.
And we're gonna, we're gonna go with her,
you know, on this path.
>> Hm.
>> And I think that really igniting the
culture and being believable
and then setting a vision is what changed
the entire business dynamic.
>> You, you've talked a lot about the
importance of culture, and resetting the
culture at HSN.
A lot of leaders talk about the importance
of culture.
I'm wondering if you can pull back the
curtain a bit for us and tactically, apart
from town halls and telling your personal
narrative,
how did you build the culture at HSN to-.
>> Yeah.
>> What it is today?
>> So the way I think about culture.
IS I've 6,000 employees, every one of them
go home
at night, every one of them has neighbors,
every one
of them [UNKNOWN] visit and somebody or
they meet a
new person and somebody goes who do you
work for?
You want that person to be your greatest
evangelist.
You want them to be proud of what they're
doing.
>> Hm.
>> And they're embedding, themselves in a
culture.
And very often when people come to visit
at HSN,
they say: oh, my God, it's almost like a
cult.
I think that's a good thing by the way, in
a good thing, not a bad one.
But so's Nike.
So's Ralph.
So you know, what I had to do was
make employee engagement the number one
priority of the company.
As, while, I was working on the brand and
the business strategy.
So with my executive leadership team, I
said we're
gonna make employee engagement our, our
number one strategy.
The second thing I did, was I was made
it very clear to the organization what my
expectations were.
And there were three sort of people.
There were the evangelists, that were
like, woo-hoo, we finally
have someone here who is gonna like take
us somewhere.
The second group of people were like,
sounds interesting, but let's see.
You know, they needed to give it time to,
you know, get through the period.
And the third people were the blockers.
They're the toxins, right?
I believe that you have to get rid of
toxicity in any company that you have.
I don't care how smart, I don't care how
talented.
I don't care how they, long they've been
there.
If somebody is going to create a toxic
environment you have to make a change.
Well they made it very clear to people.
Here are my expectations.
I think the other thing that's important.
I think too many CEOs who go into
companies that are not performing
make the incorrect assumption that
everyone
in the company is probably not talented.
It's usually because the leadership was
not inspired and it wasn't great
leadership.
So what I had to do was do a talent
assessment.
And I had a lot of talented people, that
were actually keeping the company together
throughout this time.
>> Hm.
>> So I have the same, my CFO, who is now
CFO and COO, Judy Schmeling has been there
for 19 years.
She's been my partner throughout this
whole thing.
I've had the same head of HR, I've had the
same operational people.
But I did have to bring new people in to
the front of the business who were gonna
have to understand what a lifestyle brand
was and
understand kind of what we were trying to
accomplish.
So I had to bring in a new head of
television, I had to bring in a new head
of creative.
I had to make the company become a digital
company et cetera.
But the number one thing I had to do was
inspire people
around a vision, and I think when I'm
always asked about what
a quality of leadership, that ability to
set that vision, and bring
people along with you and inspire them to
get there is critical.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, what I did was six months after I
was there I set a giant tent up.
We have a 70 acre campus in Florida.
So we have seven television studios, and,
it's huge.
And so I erected this giant tent, and I
had 2500
people, and then I broadcasted to our
other facilities outside of Florida.
And we did a multimedia presentation, and
we rolled out the new vision.
The mission, the strategy, we wrote a
Manifesto
to our customer, and we basically told the
story
of what our brand was going to be, in the
future and how we were gonna get there.
And at the time, when we showed the video
at, at that event.
We had none of these personalities, so we
had
to use other people's creative to get us
there.
But, that was what launched all our new
creative, our
mission which was to bring the joy and
excitement of
new discoveries every day to our customer,
and our vision
for being a disruptive force and changing
the landscape of retail.
And they were very bold statements at the
time considering where the
business was, but if you know, I think too
many people marginalize things.
You know my husband who's an economist and
a physicist, physicist.
He uses this expression.
Too many people are guilty of infinitesimo
incrementalism, right?
You do have to set both goals, but then
you have to give people the path to get
them.
You just can't put them out there without
the strategy.
So I think it was a combination of making
everybody feel.
They didn't have a job, they had a
mission.
And if they embraced that mission and
became evangelical in a way, that we were
gonna create something that didn't exist,
and we
were gonna change the face of the
business.
And that's what excites people to this
day.
When I have those lunches, and I go why
are you here and why do you stay?
The people, the culture
and that we are connected to our customer.
We're doing something different everyday.
The company has an intellectual curiosity,
and we're
innovating and we wanna be a company of
firsts.
>> Mm.
>> That's what they say.
>> This past year you've had a pretty big
innovation in your brand.
So you've reconcepted from, there's no
place like HSN, to, it's fun here.
Tell us, we know that brand is a lot time
than a tag line.
How do you reinvent a brand?
>> Yeah, you know, it's interesting.
I think that there are, are, are
different.
Iterations you kinda go through.
So when I first came into the company, it
truly was transformation.
I literally had to change the
way everyone, employees, the marketplace,
our customer.
When we went public, the shareholders, how
they thought
of us as a company, that we were a content
company versus a selling or shopping
company, that you
know, we were an innovation company, all
of those things.
So, that was transformational, and we
built
on the brand strategy, and the business
strategy.
Well, we're, that, a year, year and a half
ago, we were
like, okay, we now need to unlock that
next level of growth.
And we're gonna have to be a little
disruptive.
And I'm a big believer if you do not
disrupt yourself, you're going to be
disrupted by somebody else.
And I said, we need to disrupt our
business a little.
We have to reorganize how we're
structured.
We have to re-deploy assets against the
things that are gonna be more important.
It's not just watching a live show on TV,
we're gonna have to
change how we create content for digital,
and how we think of ourselves.
We're gonna have to change how we
innovate, and we're gonna
have to look for strategic partners and
how we're gonna get there.
And we're going to have to make some
massive bets
on capital expenditures around systems and
supply chain, et cetera.
But on the brand side, what I said was,
you know, we've, we've, we've articulated
there's no place like.
But now we have to answer the question
why.
Now we have to tell her why.
We told her this is unique, now we have to
tell her why.
And, so we, we did a lot of consumer work.
We met with a lot of our customers.
We under, you know we do all the time.
We work with two different companies.
We work with an insights company and then
we worked with
Doetsch to both say, what are the things
that she's feeling?
But what are the things that we have to do
to be able to bring a new
generation of customers in without
alienating our core
customer, how are we going to surprise and
delight?
So, we took all that work and we just, we
came
up with, the answer to that question is
it's fun here.
It's spontaneous.
You never know what's gonna happen next,
as I said our store changes everyday.
At least once a day, one of our team is
saying, you can't make this
stuff up, cuz you gotta remember, it's
live 24 hours a day, it's like vagous.
Right, you are there at 2 o'clock in the
morning, we are pumping
the oxygen in and you don't know what time
[LAUGH] and that's really
where, what we are about, and you know,
one of the things that
had really meaning to me, and why I really
believed in this [UNKNOWN] line.
You know, everybody remembers 2008, 2009
was pretty
[UNKNOWN] times and we [UNKNOWN] public in
August
2008 probably one of the last IPL
[UNKNOWN]
happened I'll never forget I spent the
summer of.
You know, it seemed like a good idea in
November 2007 by the way,
but Judy and I spent the summer raising
the bank financing or raising the debt.
So, imagine two women going into all
these financial institution explaining to
them why
they needed to invest in a company that
was at that time all about shopping.
But, we were determined and we raised
every penny and more, and
we did go public, our stock came out at
about $10 and
in December 2008 it was $43 at our market
cap was smaller
than our [UNKNOWN] and had nothing to do
with the fundamentals of business.
It had to do with the fact that the world
was falling apart.
And I needed to keep the organization
forward, moving forward.
It's probably one of the toughest
leadership times I ever had, because I
knew I had the fate of 6,000 people and
their families at stake.
I also knew our strategy was working.
So we really had to go out and focus on
the sell side.
But I also had to focus on my customer.
Because what I was feeling, and what my
employees were feeling, she was feeling.
The world was falling apart right around
her, and
I remember saying to our organization, she
may not
be able to buy anything right now, but
there
is never gonna be any bad news on HSN.
We're not gonna not acknowledge what's
happening, but you know what?
Instead of selling high end jewelry, we're
gonna tell her
how to save money and cook at home for her
family.
We're gonna tell her why this heater is
gonna save her a fuel bill.
Oh, we're just gonna make her feel great,
if she wants to buy a mascara.
And we're really going to respect her and
make her feel great, if she can't buy
anything.
This is a place that she can come and be a
respite for the
storm, because it is fun here, and a lot
of people weren't having fun then.
And I think that our approach, both in our
employees.
And, I, ol, the second thing about that
time, I think the companies
who have really not just survived but have
thrived post that period, are
the companies that decided to take it as
an opportunity to be offensive,
and not defensive, and invest
appropriately
and redeploy appropriately, and galvanize
against something.
I'm a big believer that, how we manage
that period was a
big part of our success and is what our
customer, responded to.
And she continues to respond.
And that's why we measure not
just employee engagement but customer
engagement.
And that idea of giving her experience is
every single day are so important.
>> And since you've weathered that storm
it [UNKNOWN] has seen phenomenal growth.
And one thing I am curious about is as a
business leader, how do you balance
initiating things to drive revenue
and spend per customer, with ensuring that
you're keeping the customers
best interest in mind and they're not
spending beyond their means?
So you can disagree with the premise, but
I think if
you get, if you get really good at what
you're doing.
>> No, no, no I think.
No let's talk about trust, right?
So, you know, trust is across all your
constituencies, right?
So if you fast forward today, we have a
$3 billion market cap, and a stock price
of 56.
We're a public company.
So, you know, my belief is that the
best companies, yes they have to execute
quarterly.
But you run your business for the long
term, number one that's really critical.
So, you talk about trust, your employees
have to have trust, your
customers have to learn to have trust,
your shareholders have to have trust.
And it's a combination of trust and
respect.
And.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I'm asked the question, how can, I was
asked the
question earlier, well you talk about
trust all the time.
But, you're kinda really selling something
to someone.
And my answer to that is, yes, cuz we're
hsn.com, not hsn.org.
And we have to have revenue, and we have
to have profits.
But we have to do it the right way.
So, I have to have trust and respect for
my customers, so when I got to the company
they were selling products that weren't of
the quality that they should be.
They had moved 30% of our calls off shore,
so she wasn't getting the service.
And they respect when she called them when
she needed
to be, and we were respecting her as an
individual.
So we completely change the dynamics and
said that we are gonna win this and i'm
willing to lose profits in the short term
to create an experience.
That was going to retain my customers in
the long term.
So, we actually spent more even when we
weren't performing as a business.
We brought all those calls back, we
created a work at
home program, we added a thousand jobs in
our local communities.
We were, that enabled us to get a higher
level.
Individual that works for us and that
program is now six
years old, and has expanded and we've
written a white paper.
Now other companies use it.
We now have some of the highest, not
just employee engagement scores, but
customer engagement scores.
So that was one.
Number two, we were very, we use a very
strong filter
in the products, the stories, and the
storytellers we were gonna have.
And we made quality our number one
priority,
because we actually have to excite the
customer twice.
Once when she feels this is a product that
she wants, and the second, when she gets
it home.
And the last thing we want to do is
disappointing someone.
We want her to get even more excited.
The third thing that we did, was we
eradicated the word selling.
In our vernacular.
And we changed it to we need to inspire
people to want to engage with the product.
So, if we are exciting our main size on
the air, and he is creating an incredible
demo, and
showing you how you can cook your dinner
more
quickly, because you are going to have the
slow cooker.
And you think that is great for your
family?
Our job is to give ideas,
give information, give education, and
hopefully entertain.
So, our customer can make an informed
decision.
An informed decision of what she can
afford.
An informed decision of is this product
right for her.
And an informed decision, so she can then
communicate that to other people.
We also made it very clear that, and we
communicate that
if you watch any of our shows, you can
return anything.
You can return anything.
Because if it doesn't make you happy, if
it's not what you thought you wanted,
we care more about you than anything else.
That was a huge paradigm shift.
For a company.
And I get letters from our customers all
the time, and I think that they
feel like they're more family than they
are customers, and I think that's really
important.
>> Speaking of family, I'm wondering if we
could
switch gears a bit and talk a bit about
your personal life, who are the people in
your
life that have inspired your sense of self
and confidence.
>> You know, I have, I'm fortunate to have
really had a few.
So, it's interesting.
My mom, got married when she was 18.
She couldn't finish, high school cuz her
mother got very sick,
My dad was 22, when they got married and
he didn't.
He was in the armed services.
And she tried for ten, 12 years, couldn't
have children.
And finally, when she was 30, my dad
worked nights in the produce business.
And his boss, who he worked for, gave
my parents some money, so they could adopt
me.
And so, from the time I was like little,
you
know, I always remember my mom's saying,
you were special.
You could do anything you want, and I felt
part responsibility you know I was kind
of a little serious you know, I get small
as younger to prove that I could do.
But, there is one thing my mother always
said
to me that has stuck with me my whole
life.
And it probably annoyed me sometimes at
the
time which it probably does my daughter
now.
But, when something would happen, whether
it was good, or whether it
was bad, if a boyfriend broke up with me,
or something good happen.
And I was complaining, or I was excited
she said
[UNKNOWN] everything in life is bechert,
means it's meant to be.
And what it's made me do, is, I never look
backwards.
I only look forward.
Because it's like that, movie, movie
sliding
door who knows what could happen if that
bad thing didn't happen, you know, what,
what, what else could've been behind the
door?
Which is why I believe I'm an optimist you
know, I
have been quoted as I only hire [UNKNOWN]
I don't hire
[UNKNOWN] I'm not very good at negative
energy, but I said
everything in life is meant to be, and I
really embrace that.
So that's probably from a personal
perspective, and then I
think from a business perspective there's
definitely been a few things.
Working for Ralph Lauren, you're really,
you're at the [INAUDIBLE] brand, right?
And I'll never forget when I was launching
a number you know, of our brands, he used
to come and walk through the show room,
and
he would show up it would be like
[INAUDIBLE].
And he would go up to something, it could
be a fixture.
Or it could be a, you know, shirt and you,
Mindy, tell
me why this Ralph Lauren before I put the
label on it.
Where did it come from, what was it
inspired by, what's the
integrity behind that product, and why
should it be part of my brand.
Second thing he taught me was, it's more
important
what you learn to say no to in your brand.
Because if you make that one mistake you
will violate the trust of
what that brand is, and there have been
quite a number of, whether
they be brands or celebrities, or
personalities that have been an
opportunity to
come to HSN, and I probably could have
done a lot of business.
But, I knew they weren't right for our
brand.
I knew they weren't right for our culture.
I knew they weren't the right kind of
people.
And sometimes you have to let business go.
If it's not the right thing for your
brand.
And then you know, Phil Knight who is
one of the most inspirational, amazing
people in
what he believes in, in terms of
inspiration
and innovation and culture and humanity is
so important.
But the one, one thing I really remember,
I was having
this conversation with him and I must have
been frustrated that one
of the people on my team, you know, I'm
like, I
can't get them to, you know, evolve, you
know, or move up.
You know, I was trying to fix people,
right.
And, he said he finally said to me, Mindy,
you will be a lot more successful.
Company will be a lot more successful.
And, you will be a lot less frustrated if
you stop
trying to make ordinary people
extraordinary
and surround yourself with extraordinary
people.
And, I always learned that, you know.
There's an extraordinary in everyone.
And it doesn't matter how many degrees you
have.
It doesn't matter what your background is.
It doesn't matter what your providence is.
You need to look for extraordinary people
with soul.
People who have the humanistic
characteristics, as well as the talent.
And then lastly, working for Barry, even
though it was only a couple of years, it's
like, idea, and I was always a risk taker,
but, really to understand what that
means in today's environment, that, you
know, you've
gotta be able to block out the external
noise, and do what you think is, is right,
even if it goes against the grain.
>> I wanna make sure we leave some time
for questions from the audience.
But before we do that, you have done a lot
of these interviews.
And I have a lot of questions [LAUGH]
we're not gonna have time to get to today.
I'm curious when you are done with an
interview, if you're
ever left thinking, I wonder why they're
not asking me x.
What should we be asking you that we're
not asking you?
>> I have found that there's a lot of
smart young people who really know what
questions to ask.
[LAUGH] I, I wish some of you were at some
of our investor conferences.
Because you ask much better questions.
You know, you know, I think too many
people,
you know, ask the, the business questions.
I think what we talked about today is
really important.
I think you, you have to ask the soul
questions.
You know, what drives people, what
motivates
people, whether it's an employee or a
customer.
And, you know, when I look at the leaders
that I respect, and
I go to all these conferences, what I
wanna hear is the why.
I wanna hear the why behind.
You know, when I go and meet
with investors, I know that they're
investing in
the company, but they're also investing in
me and they're investing in my leadership
team.
And I actually ask them to ask the tougher
questions, you know,
ask the questions of, you know, why, why
do you believe this?
Not just the numbers.
Not just the things.
What are they telling you?
How do you look at your competition.
Why do you think you're gonna be
successful?
It's the whys.
And you have to keep digging deeper you
know, particularly as
you're deciding, you know, what businesses
you wanna, wanna to be
in, in you know, I talk to people you know
a
lot and I'll say you know, what are you
looking for?
What are you looking for in a company?
And I get the business side of it and I'm
like no, no, no what are you looking for
in a
company that you think aligns with who you
are and what
your values are and is it a company poised
for growth?
Is it a company poised for success?
And I think too many people get entranced
by big.
They get entranced by size.
They gotta get entranced by opportunity,
and what
you think you can bring to the table.
And that's why that conversation about
impact is so important
to me because what impact was when I was
20 and
what I could do, and I tried to have
impact, and
I tried to make other people successful
that was my impact.
What I think of impact today and creating
value, what I think
of impact today from it personally and
philanthropy, is a very different thing.
If I've been privileged to be able to get
to this
point, I have a responsibility now to have
impact beyond myself.
So whether it's my work at UNICEF or going
into the field,
or HSN cares those are the things that are
the most rewarding.
So again, it goes back to the why.
>> I have lots of questions, I'd love to
ask you but, I wanna give you guys a
chance.
So, we're gonna open it up for five
minutes of
questions for Mindy, and then we'll close
it out of here.
>> First question from the audience here.
Twitter was Mindy, when you first arrived
at HSN, how did you
identify the people who you could, trust
and rely upon for your transformation?
>> It's a great question, and it was the
first thing I needed to do.
As I said before, I brought my leadership
team together,
as well as articulated to the company what
my personal philosophy
was, what was acceptable in behavior, and
the people and
the character that I was looking for, and
what wasn't acceptable.
We very quickly defined what the elements
of our culture were, and what people had
to do and the type of people that were
going to be successful in that culture.
And then I really had to put that through
a filter and determine who was
not going to be successful and determine
who was and make some hard decisions.
And there were hard decisions.
There were some people who, I will tell
you right now, have gone on
you know, to other companies, but I knew
that they didn't fit the future.
And they wouldn't fit with me.
And they weren't going to be a positive
you know, element of this transformation.
And they were gonna make it harder.
And you know, the, the key was is to get
in my head.
I needed people who could inspire people.
I needed people who understood what a
transition was to a lifestyle brand.
I needed people that were gonna be
evangelists and work to engage the
culture.
That had positivity, that certainly they
had to have the brains
and the intellect and the capability, but
it wasn't about a
resume, it was about who those human
beings are and more
important were they gonna make an ambition
and were they gonna commit.
fortunately, as I mentioned before, I had
some very
talented people, but what I really
appreciate is the first
people I hired, you know Bill Brand is now
our CMO and head of business development
for the corporation.
Andy Sheldon is now opening our
entertainment offices in LA.
So all the people that came in, in the
beginning,
are still there because they still think
it's a mission.
And I think that's really important.
>> Hi, I'm Dorothy Walter.
I'm MBA 1.
Thank you so much for coming in to speak
with us today.
I have a question about how you view HSN's
role in launching new brands.
What are some of the success factors and
also
risks, and how do you wrap your head
around that?
Thank you.
>> That's a great question.
I actually think of it as a privilege, to
work with new brands.
And I think in today's world, a lot of
brands,
it gets, it's harder and harder to tell
their stories, right?
Brands are distribution captive.
There are less stores.
There are less vehicles.
The places you can't tell your story,
they're very crowded.
So, to be able to help a new brand or a
younger brand,
being able to give voice to their story is
really exciting to me.
So, I get as excited about the
entrepreneur
who created this product in her garage so
her
kids could learn how to flip and fold as I
am, you know, Keith Urban and his guitar.
They're all rock stars, so what we do is
spend a lot of time trying to understand
what the brand wants to articulate and
what the DNA of that brand is.
And, you know, the way I look at it, I
have a competitor two and a half times my
size.
So if it's just about how many of these
you can
sell in the first five minutes, I'm not
gonna be very compelling.
But if my value proposition is that I'm
gonna be able
to tell your story and I'm gonna invest in
understanding your story.
And I'm gonna invest in articulating that
whether
it's through a set, whether it's through
an environment,
whether it's through a creative or
whatever that
is, and I'm gonna bring your story to
life.
That to me is a relationship.
And we will do everything possible to make
that successful.
Now that is not to say that everything
works, it doesn't.
I can do anything for a brand, but I can't
personally make
the product sale if for some reason it's
not resonating with the customer.
But we will do everything in our power,
and
we will never end a relationship
disrespectfully or abruptly.
You know, we will be very clear throughout
that process.
And we've actually had some people that we
didn't
have immediate success with, but a year
later they'd
honed their business or their product or
their brand
and we decided to relaunch them and have
success.
So what do our teams do?
Our teams are scouring you know, the world
for great products, and great stories, and
great brands.
We also have ideas, and we create them.
You know, what we're doing with Disney for
example, at the end of this month.
We saw Oz the Great and Powerful.
So we're Disney partner for Maleficent,
which is launching going
into theaters at the end of March with
Angelina Jolie.
So we went out to 50 different brands from
small to big
and we had people create products inspired
by the inspiration of the story.
And we're creating a 24-hour event on air.
So, you have a little entrepreneurial
brand next to, you know, a big brand.
But what they're all doing is just
creating inspiring stories.
And that's what's exciting for us, is to
be able to do
that.
>> You wanna take.
Okay.
>> Sure.
>> Oh.
Yeah.
One last question.
>> No pressure.
[LAUGH]
>> Hi, my name is Gillian [INAUDIBLE] I'm
an MBA too.
My question is around how your see you're
role and you're objective as a
CEO today, and I'm wondering how that's
changed since you took the role on
initially?
>> So, you know, I look at the, the CEO
role as on multiple levels right?
I am responsible for making sure I'm
creating sustainable
value for my company, which is going to
ultimately then
create value for all the constituencies we
have, whether
it's our customers, our employees or our
shareholders.
But I'm also responsible for being the
shepherd of my brands and for my company.
And I'm also responsible for creating
sustainable opportunities and success for
people.
And I take all of that very, very
seriously.
And I say all of that because sometimes,
to your earlier point, they can be
conflicting priorities.
There are times where, you know, I have to
make a decision, and I've not made the
decision to
make money in that quarter, because I'm
not gonna make
the wrong decision for the long term of
the business.
But I'm very clear about why I decided to
do something, and my share holders
understand because I've been consistent
with our strategy and our story.
For six years I've never deviated, so they
trust the decisions that I'm making, even
though
it might have a short term disruption, are
right for the long term value of the
business.
Which is why I think we have long term
shareholders and great institutions
because that really is my job.
Is to understand the choices and to make
the right
and educated choices for the long term
success of the company.
The second thing, is my job as a CEO to
really lead and be a role model
for what I do and what I say, both
internally and externally.
And it's to set the, an example.
And I take that really seriously, because
the worst thing that I
could do, is sit up here and say, we do
all of this.
And then all of a sudden, I act
differently.
Or I say something different.
It's not real and it's not authentic.
So I have to kind of live, and walk the
walk.
And whether it be about, you know, why we
launched Davidson Cares?
Or what we have to invest in, or if I
do have to, you know, consolidate a
business, and maybe I
do have to layoff some people, because, if
I don't,
I can't deploy the resources that will
take the company forward.
But anyone that knows me, knows that if I
do that, I'm gonna do it respectfully.
And people are gonna understand the
reasons why.
So I look at that role in very broad
terms.
>> Mindy, most of us here today are
thinking
about what to do next now that school is
wrapping
up and charting career paths of our own
with some
uncertainty, and this is a quote that you
said last
year at in New York, and this is something
that
I know you tell your daughter, I'm
wondering if you
could expand on it in closing for us as
MBAs
and how you might encourage us to leap
into it.
>> I think it's really important that
people not be afraid of risk.
Now, there is a big difference between
risk and suicide, okay.
I just want to be clear.
And what I mean by that is, don't only
look at what's in front of you today.
Don't only look at what's out there today.
Find, take the insights of everything that
you've learned.
Take the insights and intellectual
curiosity
you have to look what's out there.
And say what do I want to be part of?
What do I want, you know, what do I want
to get that experience, right?
What do I see as growing?
What do I see as, you know, that, that
next thing?
It's kind of like we're looking at a lot
of acquisitions right now and
I'm looking for those things that are
going to have the big growth
opportunities, right?
And you have to decide what level of risk
you're gonna take at any given point in
your career.
But the time when you can really do it
and have the different experiences is, is
early, right?
I, I had a, I had a number of friends who
I said to them, you are miserable, right?
Why are you still doing this?
Cuz they felt trapped.
Never be in a position to feel trapped.
Believe in yourself enough that you need
to find those things that are.
Cuz if you are inspired, and you are
excited, and you are apart
of something, you are probably gonna be
successful because you're doing what you
love.
And you know, it's interesting, my husband
went to school, got his
undergraduate, his maters and his post
graduate in applied mathematics and
physics.
He's like a real geek, he said he was
Steven Hawkins, right.
And he goes I don't think I wanna do it,
then he went to law school,
you know, and then he went, and he
practiced law for five years, and he was
miserable.
And, this kinda went, I, I met him, and he
said you know what, I, I can't do this.
And he just decided to give up law and
made a segue
and said, I wanna figure out maybe how to
go into banking
which he did, and he went and he said I'm
gonna make
my segue from, into derivatives and swap
documentation and went into finance.
>> He had some backup options.
[LAUGH]
>> but, but you know, he's always been one
of those people
that, you know, at his true heart and soul
I think he's
an academic, but he's got this incredible
intellectual curiosity and the most
important thing for him is, I need to fill
my intellectual curiosity.
So that was always his guiding post.
You know, mine was I gotta be inspired and
I have to
be creative, and I have to have an outlet
for my creativity.
The most important thing you can do, and
the most empowering
thing you will ever do throughout your
entire life, is know yourself.
Know yourself.
I think self-awareness is the key to
everything.
>> We spend a lot of time on that [LAUGH]
here at Stanford Business School.
>> Yeah.
Know, know the good, the bad, and the
ugly.
Right?
Okay?
>> You're on the right path.
[LAUGH].
>> Trust me, you know, I know what my
derailers are, right?
But, it's empowering if you know what
you're made of, because then you
can put those things through the filter of
what's real and what's important.
And, when people work for you, if you're
really honest,
and you're willing to tell people what
your strengths are, and
your willing to tell them what your
weaknesses are, there gonna
trust you a lot more, because your willing
to share that.
And we have a joke, we all know what our
derailers are.
Mine, I'm not very patient sometimes.
One of the other guys is mischievous, so
he'll try and you know?
When, when you're under stress, you have
to know what it is.
So we can be in a meeting, and we'll be
able to call each other out.
And go, you're derailing, right?
And I, I just think it's, you know,
self-awareness is empowering.
So know everything you can about yourself,
know
what gets you excited, and then find that
path.
>> Mindy thank you so much for being here
with me.
>> Thank you for having me.
>> We really appreciate it.
[SOUND].
>> Thank you.
[MUSIC]